our next guest who is the host of
tbs's go big show you can't go small
here
no no no no you cannot go small you have
to go big
uh celebrity judges include our friends
of pro a lot of friends of our program
right here cody rhodes snoop dogg also
rosario dawson and jennifer nettles who
is the person that tbs said we choose
him
to make sure that everything stays on
track we choose him
to make sure the funny is the funniest
we choose him
the him being bert christ you're back
here in the rich eisenhower how are you
bert
dave magadan
no no okay i told you by the way i told
you that is you've been waiting
you've been waiting like two years to
correct the record let's start off
our interview hitting the wayback
machine
tell me the story you told me
uh with don mattingly at the center of
it
instead of dave i'm so guilty of this
all throughout life one time i told my
wife i almost got in a fight with a guy
who looked like louis ck
but instead of saying louis ck i said
louis anderson
a less impressive story
yeah you're right you're not wrong
sometimes facts matter
so so what's the story again bert i
forget it a little bit here
remember got in trouble
in high school and we had to run
something called player appreciations
during
our uh lunch period or homeroom or
whatever
so we go out to the field and at the
field was fred mcgriff
and i did i almost did it again i want
to say don mattingly but it's dave
magden
who had gone to jesuit and we're jogging
and they're
taking bp and dave
hit the dot and it hit bo beer in the
back of the
in the back of the just back and he just
hits the ground hard right he's like oh
my god
and we turn around and they're like kind
of laughing but they're like sorry
sorry guys and we're like oh my god i
went like i can't believe you got hit
he's like i know crazy we turn around we
start to keep jogging
facing the outfield and he gets hit
again and we turn around
he's like i told you i could do it
now i thought it was don mattingly which
is such a better story
it was dave magden so dave magadan was
purposefully
with fred mcgriff maybe egging him on
aiming for you
in the outfield is what you're saying
for us going opposite field
anyone anyone that can go opposite field
i'm very impressed by
what's interesting about this story is i
knew i said john mattingly
and you lit up and i was like wow that's
so odd that he's a big dumb
i'm thinking dave maggot in my head
going i mean he had a career but it
wasn't like no
through the room and you're like that is
my favorite player i'm like
did you go to jesuit high school too
and the second i get home i call i get
calls
from beau beer who's like it was dave
magdalene
oh my god
yes yes so and
i'm like saying i hung out and partied
with daniel craig
but instead it was jenny craig
[Laughter]
yes it's a big difference there is there
is a big difference in all that
oh my gosh did so did you play ball when
you were younger bert did you actually
oh by the way yes and can i tell you
i've come upon a realization
when it comes to sports now i fell out
of love with baseball i was a big
baseball player
got recruited to go to a couple of
colleges went to walk on a florida state
played literally one day and then walked
off and was like i'm gonna do drugs
and so i literally by little that i know
i could have done both
mark mcguire now so um i
i fell out of love with baseball and i'm
watching ken burns's baseball
documentary on cbs yes and i'm looking
at videos
from like the 80s when i was in love
with it i'm like why isn't baseball
as sexy as back then when you'd watch
plays of the week you know this week in
baseball why isn't it and i came to a
realization
it's the same reason that i now love
porn
is back then when i was a kid i could
watch those baseball things
and those baseball plays and go i'll be
doing that this weekend
on the little league diamond the same
way i look at porn i go i'm going to do
that at home
now i watch baseball i go i can't do any
of that i'll never do that there's no
connection with the art
like i don't get to go out and dive into
a diamond like aussie smith
i'm out of it so that's my realization
yes i did play baseball
[Laughter]
a simple question uh that led to some
some of me recalling my innocent times
of watching like the baseball bunch you
know with johnny bench
and and then and then you and then you
go all you know
uh all porn industry on me right there
um
so giving i guess new meaning to triple
play bert right
is what you're saying oh dude i mean
every kid
anyone listening right now that's a
baseball fan knows that then when you
watched pete rose slide into third base
that one memorable slide to the third
base head first
you could just go you could go to your
backyard fill the backyard up with water
and go do pd's yourself
no doubt no doubt about bert crusher
here on the rich eisen show
uh go big show uh on tbs so i guess
that's
it that's all you've been doing is going
big when you say you had mattingly it
was really maggoting or anything like
that so you're used to
so you're you are you are used to doing
this tell me about go
big show bert what do you got here
amazing it really is an amazing show
we went down to we went down to macon
for one month stayed in a bubble
snoop dogg zarya dawson me cody rhodes
jennifer nettles and
it's basically it really is like an
extreme talent show like it is
it is talents that you would discover
you have in the back of a field in
indiana
to your friends drunk and you go well
how am i ever going to make money doing
that
i can hold 20 rattlesnakes in my mouth
who's going to pay me for that
we will we will it is so much fun
it was a blast to shoot it is going to
be a blast to watch we've got alligators
monster trucks rattlesnakes the guy gets
in the sleeping bag with rattlesnakes i
hope i'm not
spoiling but it is it is out
through the world death defying fun
crazy
feats of strength it was a blast and
then you got snoop dogg
who basically was stoned to his bejesus
the entire time i mean that guy really
is the real deal yes
he is the real deal
oh yeah you know uh years ago when i was
uh
running my 40-yard dash uh for charity
at the nfl scouting combine
uh you know he was so cool to want me to
run in his shoes which i think were
adidas at the time and then
the league stepped in and it was a issue
with
not being the official shoe of the
combine or whatever and he was really
cool and i had to call him up and say
that i couldn't do it but when i went to
go visit him at the combine he went
there
he was there and he was going to perform
that night and i got off the elevator i
knew which room he was in
can i tell you when i just got off the
elevator bert
i could follow my nose all the way to
the room that's a fact
that happened this is embarrassing to
say yes
but one night one night i do this stunt
with the guy and he goes you do that son
we'll drink together tonight i was like
nice
so one night we get off we don't drink
that night the next night i'm going to
our trailers we're going our trailers
we're next to each other
and he's about to go in his trailer and
he's like yo bert and i was like what's
up he's like
you want to take a shower and i was like
sure he's like all right come on over
and so i was like wow that's odd
snoop wants to take a shower together
i'm like it's snoop you know you want to
have a
story of you hanging with snoop so i was
like okay
so i go over to his door and his
bodyguards are there i was like yes
snoop
wants me to come in and take a shower
and they're like oh inside
and so i was like oh my god this is
going to be weird if i knock on the door
i get in
i'm already shirtless right i'm already
certain oh that's just sure
of course and soup's like what's up i
was like you want to take a shower
and he looked at me and he goes what and
i said you said you wanted to take a
shower and he goes
no i said you want to take a shot and i
went oh
and then he's silent and he looks at me
and he goes
you came over to shower
and i was like yeah i guess i would have
taken a shower with you all fell
and you're shirtless during this
conversation
and literally he's frozen and he's like
tequila
and i think even if yeah i would like to
eat in the tower
that is fantastic that is all just
fantastic oh my god how much she was the
best
did you try to uh speak to the producers
of this show and convince them to allow
you shirtless and hosting it shirtless
because we noticed no they were they
were they were not fans of that but
i'm really i'm a tactile person so the
second we i would wear a shirt for
shooting
and then i would just take it off the
second so i was shirtless the entire
show and it was funny the first day
everyone's like what's that guy doing
shirtless and then by the end everyone's
like
no one even noticed it
they're used to it oh my god so but you
didn't even attempt to say hey you know
what i do my best work
shirtless so let's do this shirtless and
that wasn't even right
and i ripped my shirt off one time
there's a spoiler alert i'm telling cbs
it's like please don't share this
okay um so we had an archer we had an
archer
uh attempt a shot that he couldn't do
and then i said hey can i try it and
immediately
everyone's like don't try it this is
stupid we have a
live weapon you know me i'm already
moving forward and everyone's like
there's a weapon on set
everybody clear like everyone's losing
their mind soup is of course like
there's no way you're doing it
cody starts videotaping it and i from
about 50 yards
bang out a bullseye with a bow and arrow
come on and
and they're all rolling cameras they're
all rolling cameras
right i bang it off snoop's mouth is
dropped
rip my shirt off and i go i'm the
machine immediately
i think i understand this man you talk
his language
oh my gosh are you making a machine
movie bert yeah yeah we are we're
doing
did you just lose him we lost him oh
just forget that it is
awesome it is awesome and i am doing a
cycle of steroids
all right so we just lost you right
there after i said so are you are doing
a machine movie
bert yes i am doing a machine movie it
shoots in prague i am doing a cycle of
steroids
okay let's take it one at a time prague
why prague because
that's where it all took place right it
looks the most like russia we're not
gonna get
shaken down every left turn we take okay
so and then and then
um you're taking steroids i'm gonna do a
cyclic steroids
because i really want that like power
factor where i release a picture of
myself and everyone's like
what the and then i'm gonna take a cycle
of steroids up until the first day of
shooting yes and then we'll reshoot it
we'll shoot that and then i'll start
gaining weight until the end of the
movie you do realize though bert and i i
don't speak from experience here
uh but steroids helps you recover from
workouts like you do have to still work
out
like steroids doesn't just turn you into
a muscle-bound individual you still have
to do the work
bert you know that right there's a lot
of different steroids that do different
things
so i'm going to take i think the one i'm
looking into is winstrol i think it just
gets you shredded okay
all right so winstrol okay got it you
you're going for like the kumail namjani
like
shock factor that everyone oh yeah but
i'll be taking steroids so people won't
even remember him
he's got he's got natural physique i'm
going for luke ferrigno
like what is wrong with this guy there's
so like seriously
he is terrorists and then i'm gonna go
and talk shows and go oh yeah it is
steroids
it's awesome like i'm gonna really kind
of lean into the steroids
[Music]
bert uh i gotta tell you that mike that
might not be uh
a good idea but uh you know hey if if
that's what you that's the way you would
hey you you were willing to take a
shower
i could be like i could be like uh i
could be like the voice of steroids in
the new generation
i was like no they actually it's like
how many movie stars do steroids get
ripped for a part anyway right and then
don't admit it right would it be
refreshing to see because if you're a
comedian and you're doing it you gotta
go oh yeah yeah i'm yoked
and i'm juiced to the guilt like
literally
literally i cannot find my testicles
[Laughter]
oh man the host of go big show
premiering on tbs at 9 00 pm eastern
on thursday night also the host of bert
cast a weekly podcast
um the machine bert crusher himself uh
is can can bill burke get your role on
the mandalorian
season three what do you think you're
one of the funniest we did a podcast
yesterday
sure and i said i didn't know that john
favreau directed the mandalorians yeah
and and wrote it like oh no he's like
he's like
awesome and i go bill i'm sorry i gotta
apologize like i haven't watched it
you know bill's like yeah i watched it i
was like no i'm not like i'm not like a
big star wars guy so i go i'm i'm sorry
i haven't watched it
and i go what's this season about and
bill freezes and he goes
i haven't watched any of the birds here
i wish you hadn't asked me that question
i thought i was getting away clean
he goes i don't know man i've been busy
i haven't watched i'm not a star wars
guy either
my god you're in the mandalorian he
hasn't even watched it
i gotta tell you it's just it's just
it's just wild to hear the uh the
masshole accent right in the middle of
some star wars venture you know it's
really
wild but he's really good in it bill's
he's he's really good in it man
he crushed it dude he's awesome we do we
do bill bert every week
right and every week we laugh his scare
and bill really
really has no filter and really does not
care about
cancel culture he doesn't listen to it
so you want to talk about refreshing
we were talking we spent an entire
podcast talking about world war ii
as if we were born in 1930 like it was
it was it's awesome i love podcasting
with that guy well and i i love
listening to it and watching you guys
and
and bert uh let's do this more often
let's not do this every two years and uh
where you know and certainly you if you
need to ever get the words dave magnan
off your chest
don't wait so long okay don't wait so
long i love you guys
i love you guys and i love that you guys
shouted me out when you were talking
about the machines
and that and and who are the machines
which ones are the real machines
i love being in that conversation i got
so i get all my friends from florida
start texting me and they're like are
you guys just talking about you
guys are talking about you i love it i
will take it any time and congrats burt
on everything let's do this more often
really love you guys right back at you
on both twitter and instagram his career
blowing up hey you watched all the way
to the end
thanks for that watch more right here